- [Instructor] What we're going to do
in this video is get some practice
estimating adding decimals.
Here it says 12.93 plus 6.1
is approximately equal to,
this little squiggly equal
sign means approximately
equal to, so try to estimate
this and pick the right choice.
Pause the video and try to do that.
Alright, now let's work
through this together.
We could work this out by
hand, but the whole goal here
is estimation, so if I were
doing this in my head I'd say,
well, look, 12.93 is a
little bit less than 13,
and 6.1 is a little bit more than six.
And it's actually nice because
when I rounded I went down
on this number and I
went up on this number.
I went up 700ths to get to 13
and I went down 1/10th to
get to six, so I feel good
when I add them up that we're
going to get pretty close
to the actual answer.
13 plus six is equal
to 19, and lucky for us
that that is one of the choices.
There's multiple ways that you
could try to estimate things.
For example, you could do a
little finer of an estimation.
You'd say, this is
approximately 12.9 plus 6.1,
and then you'd say, 12 plus
six is 18, and then, 9/10ths
plus 1/10th is another one,
so you'd say this is 18
plus one, and you'd say,
okay, that, once again gets me
pretty close to 19,
or, this gets me to 19.
Let's do another example.
Here we're told five plus one plus 4.91
is approximately equal to
what, so, pause this video
and see if you can figure that out.
Try to estimate it, try to
do it without any paper.
The way I would do it is
actually very similar to the way
we just did the last one.
5.1 is approximately equal to five,
and,
is approximately equal
to five, and 4.91 is also
approximately equal to five.
I rounded to the nearest
whole number in either case,
and so, that would be equal to 10.
Once again, it makes sense
because we rounded down here
and we rounded up here, we
rounded down to go from 5.1
to five, and we rounded up to go
from 4.91 to five.
If you're rounding down in
both cases, or rounding up
in both cases your estimate
might get a little bit further
from your actual answer,
so you might want to be
a little bit careful.
Alright, so in this last
example, once again,
pause the video and see if you can
work through it on your own.
We're just going to do
the same thing here.
This is going to be approximately equal
to three plus, I rounded down, 3.14,
rounded to the nearest
whole number, three.
5.92 rounded to the nearest
whole number is six.
And once again, just like I
mentioned in the previous ones,
this is good because I am rounding down
from 3.14 to three, I took away 1400ths,
and I add 800ths to 5.92,
so it's going to get me reasonably close
to my actual answer, and
so, three plus six is equal
to nine, which is, indeed,
one of the answers here.
And this is actually
interesting, you're not always
going to see a multiple
choice, so if you're trying
to estimate things, but in
this case, you know that just
three plus five is going
to be eight, and so this
can't be the choice.
Then you're going to have
eight plus whatever 1400ths
plus 9200ths is, and you
know that's more than one,
so you know our answer's going
to be a little bit over nine.
Once again, nine is a good approximation.